good morning Hank it's Tuesday so I
really loved your video about
perspective and in the beginning of it
you were like everybody right in the
comment box no math allowed no Google
searches how long ago you think it was a
million seconds ago and my immediate
thought was that's easy 12 years of
course it turns out that it is in fact
12 days I'm not very good at measuring
time as longtime nerdfighters will no
doubt remember that once acted as if a
minute had 100 seconds and it's very
embarrassing anyway all that made me
think about perspective and where I was
a million imagined seconds ago so here's
a story I was 24 and my longtime
girlfriend had just broken up with me
and I was living in Chicago in what had
been our apartment with what had been
our cat and I was pretty depressed I
thought the depression was a result of
having been dumped but in retrospect
getting dumped was probably at least
partly a result of the depression you
know with it's incumbent like obsessive
thinking patterns and self focus and
inability to like do anything also I was
trying to write a novel but I hadn't
written a sentence I liked it more than
a year and while I did have like a great
job at bookless magazine and wonderful
colleagues and friends and a great
family I was really losing it had to
give you some context a lot of days the
only thing I would eat or drink would be
one two-liter bottle of sprite which is
a bad nutrition strategy on many levels
including the fact that you lose a lot
of weight and despite the lemon and lime
flavoring you eventually get scurvy but
before I got for the scurvy point I
called my parents one night and we all
agreed that I needed to come home so I
woke up the next morning and I quit my
job actually I tried to quit my job but
the publisher book was Bill out was like
why don't you just take a leave of
absence for a couple weeks see if you
can get well enough to come back to work
which in retrospect is one of the nicest
things anyone ever did for me also he
gave me a note I still have to this day
John I stopped by to say goodbye hope
all goes well and you're back here in
two weeks with an appetite that we put a
longshoreman to shame now more than ever
watch Harvey bill bill had been bugging
me for like three years to watch this
old black-and-white movie Harvey so my
dad drove up to Chicago and then we
drove back to Orlando together I got
into daily therapy I started taking a
much better medication for me and I
watched Harvey mag as you know I am very
suspicious of epiphanies because I think
people have life-changing revelations
all the time to turn out not to actually
change their lives that said all I know
is that I woke up the
after watching Harvey feeling a little
bit better and in all the years since I
have never felt quite as hopeless as I
did before I watched RV the movies about
this guy Elwood P Dowd whose best friend
is a six foot tall invisible white
rabbit and there is one line in the
movie that I think really did change my
life
oh it says my mother used to tell me
that in this world Elwood you must be oh
so smart or oh so pleasant well for
years I was smart I recommend Pleasant
two weeks later I went back to book
Weston within six months I handed Ilene
Cooper my mentor forty single-spaced
pages of the story that eventually
became Looking for Alaska God I want to
pretend that everything was rosy I still
missed my ex-girlfriend I was still
really screwed up and those 40 single
spaced pages were pretty terrible but
with a million seconds of perspective or
I guess 365 million seconds I see a life
that I am now very grateful to have
beginning to happen but I didn't know
that then Hank all I knew is that I was
a little less hopeless than I had been
you can't know when an experience will
mean to future you until you are future
you you need millions of seconds of
perspective which ultimately only time
can buy but until then there is always
the gift of Elwood P Dowd there's a
great moment in the movie where a
mailman says Dellwood beautiful day
isn't it and Elwood replies every day is
a beautiful day Hank I'll see you on
Friday